you're watching game sports coverage of
e3 2021
almost forgot what year it was there and
it is my pleasure to be joined by
bill and nate from nintendo treehouse
how are you doing folks
hi doing great great you've just shown
off the nintendo direct we're recording
this straight off the nintendo direct
and um
showed us some really cool stuff there
so what we're going to do is we're going
to talk about some of that stuff but i'm
also going to test you on how well you
know your nintendo direct which should
be fun
so first questions first the nintendo
direct opening animation depicts a bunch
of red arrows moving from left to right
how many individual arrows appear on the
screen during this
17 i'm gonna say
14. bill did you say 17 i did
you nailed it
did you count that did you know that
ahead of time i know everything
i spent ages counting that there's one
arrow that just kept going between
the letters of nintendo direct it was so
annoying for me anyways i'm working on
that
uh smoothly transitioning from that why
kazuya in smash brothers
interesting pick very interesting pick i
think uh
i mean obviously he's an iconic
character from tekken
um you know going back to the early
games in that series but
is also one who's kind of evolved over
time i think mr sakurai
talks a little bit about uh about his
interest in that character but um
there will probably be a lot more on
that when we see
mr sakurai presents hitting later this
month where he's going to go into quite
a bit of detail
on the character the move set and and
how he's incorporated into
uh super smash bros ultimate so at one
point in the
uh showcase there for the smash brothers
part uh kazuya throws a character into a
volcano before activating his devil mode
what character was it
i think the last one was min min
no no it was marth i'm going with marth
bill there definitely was another one
after min men
um yeah
i i don't know now you got it it was
much
it wasn't awful he gave him a little
extra oomph too he threw him like a
little higher he knew it was the last
yeah
he did so in terms of picking characters
at now at this point um
how are you kind of i mean you're
running out of characters
or that you've promised anyway you've
got like one left i think it is right
um how do you approach or how is do you
have any insight into how the team is
approaching picking that character you
gotta go out with a bang right
everyone obviously is like put crash
bandicoot in smash but
what are you guys thinking do you know
what the inside do you have any
inclination of what they're trying to go
for there
just finishing it up i think they're
probably like this at this point
to the internet like stop telling me
what to do
i don't know bill it's like i i have a
feeling that um
in general you always know that you're
never gonna to please everybody there's
far too many picks out there right now
so
um i do agree though it should end with
a bang
so crash bandicoot then yes uh kazuya
in the smash gameplay demo has a 10-hit
combo
what is the official name of that move
as shown on screen during the direct
oh nate you should know this one as well
i think it was just 10 hit combo wasn't
it bill
uh i thought it you know
because i'm confusing it with the the
final smash
uh i guess i'll also go with 10 hit
combo
you're correct it is 10 hit conflict
so nintendo's a very wholesome company
but you've once again decided to release
a game that ruins friendships and tears
families apart
uh interesting approach for to go with
an all-star
version of a super mario party what does
that allow you to do in terms of putting
together a
package for fans of uh mario party
well for me it allows me to revisit all
the games i worked on on the n64
which was so long ago but i mean
honestly i think
what's great about uh super about mario
party all-stars is that
with it being button controls it becomes
the first mario party game on switch
that's fully compatible with nintendo
switch light
um it also of course brings back the
board games from the n64 which i think
everybody loves
um i'm a big fan of kind of the the dual
the 1v1 dual mini games that we
used to see in mario party 2 which i
think will also be
making a return here and um and then
you know i do think you know super mario
party is going to remain
a a game of choice for people who maybe
are new to the switch system
or who prefer to play with joy-con
controls and that super mario party
all-star or mario party all-stars is
going to be um they're super superstars
getting that wrong too many stars
mario party superstars is really going
to be i think the game for people that
have either
already played super mario party or are
long time mario party fans
and are really eager to kind of dig back
into the roots of the series
awesome i'm not sure if you're aware of
the discussion around it but the uh
the stage with the cake has got a giant
version of donkey kong's
let's call it a dumper on show so uh you
might want to look into that because the
internet definitely is
so uh mario party superstars rosalina
rolls a fat snowball and then pushes it
into another character
do you remember what character was the
victim of this horrible incident
i am going to say it was
donkey kong himself oh nate do you
remember what character it was
luigi okay but it was in fact
birdo oh gosh i was i was getting
infertile too
uh one of my highlights for for the
showcase obviously i'm a huge metroid
fan
um i was gonna wear the metroid t-shirt
but i thought
it would be i was going to wear the uh
the one with the
outline of samus's visor which was real
cool
but metroid dread that's the exact one
that was the one that would have been
awkward if i'd worn it
uh uh metro dread's been knocking around
for what
16 years now as a thing publicly
um and it was you know thought to be in
environment limbo and then reference
then corruption and then some people
said it was completed and
um kind of how much of what we see today
is is represented in that lineage or is
this something that was kind of like
entirely thrown away and rebuilt from
the ground up i think
you know obviously mr sakamoto would
really be the one to answer that
question in detail
he he touched on this a bit in in the uh
the interview that he gave that we aired
right after
the direct in the sense that the core
idea
of samus being pursued by this
relentless uh
enemy i think is is really the germ that
was always metroid dread and
really what he um articulated was that
he's really waiting for technology to
catch up
and you know technology and the perfect
partner in the form of mercury steam
which you know after their work on
metroid samus returns proved that they
just
understand metroid the dna of what makes
a metroid game a metroid game and so
you know as far as the particulars of
exactly how much he doodled out on
cocktail napkins as far as the overall
game is
safely locked within mr sakamoto's head
but i think suffice to say that
what we've seen of that emmy gameplay
where you're you know
the sense of creeping dread as you're
wandering through those zones
that i think probably emerged intact
from 16 years ago
do you think that um there's more i mean
like it's hard to say
probably but do you think there's more
of an opportunity now to have like these
classic side-scrolling metroid games
will have
more of a presence within nintendo's
kind of future because you know
they've been gone for so long and now
they're back
um do you reckon this is something that
you the company wants to explore a
little further
and what can people do like metroid fans
like myself to show that you know
we really want this to continue we don't
want metroid to go into a vault again
for another
20 years or something like how do we how
do we make sure that doesn't happen
well i certainly wanted to continue i
mean i grew up with metroid games as
well they were some of the first games
that i played
i've always loved them and feel like
it's a genre to itself that certainly
never
should never ever go away so i'd say
you know certainly play this game that's
step one
um when it comes to supporting it and uh
i have a feeling that you're gonna
really like what you what you
what you experience yeah i think the
thing that the one thing i would add you
know
i mean as mentions metroid
are defining i think everybody
recognizes that and when you look at
how sakamoto has defined this game as
sort of
closing the the story arc of the the
five game
series of 2d metroid games um to me this
is a moment that
whether you are a metroid fan or not
whether you've never played the game
ever this is sort of one of those
moments in gaming
that everyone needs to experience you
know and that to me you know for a
metroid fan like yourself is get that
message out
let people know you know this is a
series that has defined a genre
and this is going to be a pinnacle
moment in that series you've got to try
this out
um that that to me is the the message
that i'd like to see
all metroid fans delivering is there any
more of an impetus to kind of
make classic metroid games more
available like i know super metroid is
pretty much on everything at this point
but you know fusion's a
classic and outside of i think in the
3ds ambassador program you can't really
get it like
is there any discussions happening like
we were releasing a
sequel to what is effectively a sequel
to fusion but there's a decent chance
that a whole bunch of people a
generation of people
can't play fusion so how do you approach
that the way that
each of the games is designed is as yes
there's
there's connective tissue between all of
the games and there's a story arc
between them
but each game does actually a really
solid job of reintroducing
what's happened prior in the series so
you can sort of start at any point
and then it also over the course of the
action exploration will sort of drip
feed these
little bits of story to you um and you
can piece it together
i would also say that as we're as we're
you know approaching launch
um you can expect to see a kind of a
steady cadence of information
that will help get people who are new to
the series up to speed on
on what metroid is who samus erin is
and what the what the story has been up
until now it's also never the wrong time
to go
on nso and play super metroid
i'm doing it constantly trust me
um what's your in the metrics what's
your fastest clear time
oh i don't play fast i play i play slow
and i play to absorb the atmosphere
and i play it too to just love it for
where it is like i often will boot
up and just watch the title screen i
think that's the best title screen ever
created in a video game so
um i i take it slow and steady when it
comes to the trade
so in the metroid red kia there are a
number of emmys
in the background behind samus do you
remember how many there are
behind cens seven
bill five
nate is right nate knows he's right as
well it's like
let's just move on sorry a couple times
as soon as he answered i i had to go
with something different
no matter what i said it was gonna be
wrong uh
he's on it he's on it uh so not that i'm
complaining but
why why was now the right time to bring
advanced wars back
why wouldn't it be the right thing i
mean why wouldn't
why wasn't it the right time for the 15
years where everyone was going on about
advanced wars coming back like why is it
now
well i mean you know every every team i
think has uh
has different projects that they're
working on and and uh
certainly we've seen a resurgence with
fire emblem
over the years but certainly here in
north america
many of us myself probably being a front
of the line
are big advance wars fans and and so i
think
you know personally i'm just really
happy to see that we it's back um
and that we were able to announce it
today because i do think it's um
it's a series that is worthy of a lot of
love i i have i have a great amount of
passion for it myself
yeah i keep my keypad ds3ds with me at
all times because of advanced wars so
i'm so glad to see it come back
i'm glad to see it come back because my
son
lost my old cartridges and all of the
play time that i had into them so
um only only time i'll ever call him out
for that but that did happen
well with both of those games included
that is
so much gameplay i mean i can't even
remember how long the second game was
but it
felt like hundreds of hours in that game
yeah it did feel like a long game but
i'm excited to get back in
can you clarify who's developing it i
know the site says intelligent systems
is it intelligent systems or are they
is there a call developer or anything
like that in fact we
we just confirmed earlier today that the
developer is
actually way forward and they are
working together
with consultation and advice both from
nintendo and from intelligent systems on
the project
fantastic that is a great team to on
that yeah we
we love working with them we've been
fans of them for a while uh what is
the move stat for the medium tank in
advance wars
when you got it man i have no idea let's
go
it was on the screen for a whole two
seconds
i have no idea on this one bill you got
it you got to save us
i uh the medium tank is
uh
five no four
no wait hang on five it's five
you sure yes
that is correct yes
well done well done bill almost good job
uh the game and watch zelda uh kind of
collaboration there
really cool super excited about that my
one immediate thing was
oh god am i gonna be able to buy this
can you talk a bit about uh
kind of availability and are you
prepared for it to be
uh like super super in demand or or
or should i brace for another like um i
don't know
classic situation where it's just going
to be gone and i'll have to be begging
people to try and
find it for me well hopefully we
we the special edition of metroid dread
is already unavailable so
like i looked away from my screen for
five minutes and then i came back and it
was gone and i was like oh
great yeah it's um i mean it's certainly
challenging these days
i think with any um just the
perfect storm of of covid and and people
getting out to retail and
uh you know generally a high demand for
everything i think makes it challenging
but um certainly with uh with the
collection of zelda gaming watch we'll
we'll hopefully be able to provide
enough to cover for
what we expect to be a really
enthusiastic response i certainly know
i need to grab at least three um one for
me and
and a couple for a couple friends so uh
we will certainly do our best to
anticipate that demand and uh make sure
it's available
tim this is your chance to ask nate if
you were one of those friends yeah
nate am i'm
uh moving on to breath of the wild the
secret to breath of the world
um one of the main
things i in my mind is like how much
more of a focus from what you can say
is narrative for the game because it's
very much you know the original game was
a very light touch on the narrative do
you know if there's but everything i
see of it it seems like it's setting up
a very strong
story to tell is that the right way to
come out
and think about it or should we brace
for something should the people who are
obsessed with law get their pens and
papers ready well i think
certainly i think those people are
probably getting their pens and papers
ready anyways
but i absolutely think it'll it'll have
a strong story but i'm also
uh you know of the mind that that uh
legend zelda breath of the wild had a
very strong story it was
it was just told in a very interesting
way
you know the gameplay design was such
that
really had to design a narrative based
around not knowing whether or not
everybody would actually
find all the pieces of the narrative so
the way that you pieced the story of
what happened
100 years prior together based on you
know finding memory locations
you know experiencing cutscenes that
really not everybody would see
i thought it was a really interesting
way to do things and um and at the end
you know for somebody like me who
absolutely covered every inch of hyrule
in that game and saw everything
really felt like it ended up being a
very satisfying story and i expect
um absolutely the same from the new game
but of course we're
we're not providing any real details on
that uh there's various points where you
can see
like a a snippet of link with long hair
and that's intrigued me um can link grow
a bit do you know do you guys know if
that's possible
like are you asking because you also
have long hair and a beard
yeah i i would love to see a long hair
beard link but i'm just wondering like
is he too young
to like does he have it does he have the
hormones to grow a bit or not is that
i think like you need to figure that out
and then maybe reissue the hyrule
historia to like
update that stuff or a mustache i do
want to on the subject of hair i do want
to give a shout out to
in the re the first breath of the wild
game the ancient armor i don't know if
you ever got that full set but if you
wore that set
he achieved maximum mullet on that one
he had the longest yeah
um so yeah i i'm holding out hope as as
you
are for uh some some serious hairstyles
yeah i mean
yeah if you can just like let arnold my
son know that a beard would go a long
way
please i think i mean like the the
fan images are going to be incredible if
that happens because everyone loves a
beard
um during the legend of zelda portion of
the discussion
anu was wearing a badge on his shirt
what was the badge of
i'm going to just go safe and say a
triforce but that's an easy answer
interesting fail
i am going to say that he was wearing
a pen and the shape of
the z logo for zelda
oh both wrong both wrong
nate you were the closest it was the
royal crest
i was gonna say that it was very small
it was very small
a couple of final questions for you both
uh
interesting lack of animal crossing
during the director
um can you talk a bit about that mainly
because people are like
we're still playing armor crossing
what's the nintendo's what's the
decision behind not having animal
crossing and what's the kind of plan
going forward for animal crossing is
there still life in it there i was just
playing animal crossing this morning
and absolutely there's life in it uh
left you know we do still plan to
continue to support it with updates
um didn't you know i think in general we
were so jam-packed with announcements
for
for this direct that maybe it just
wasn't the uh the right time for more
for more of it but we absolutely plan to
continue to support in the future
and then the final question just for me
where
where is bayonetta 3 like is it is it
still
does it still exist like we're dying out
here is there any
do you go do you are you going to show
it to us again ever what's the deal here
it definitely still exists i can confirm
it
uh sweet i'm that's not that i will even
go
one further and say not only does it
exist but it's it's progressing well
oh good see you played it then well uh
you know i think we have a habit of we
like to show things when we're ready to
show them
um and certainly we like to show things
uh when
i think the developers are ready to show
them so we'll uh
we didn't have it here at e3 but stay
tuned
oh i appreciate you telling us that bill
nate
thank you so much for your time today
and for uh entertaining
the quiz shenanigans i when i conduct
quizzes everyone's a winner so as far as
i'm concerned you both won
great job
[Music]
you